NARRATOR: In April of 2014,
ancient astronaut theorist
Giorgio Tsoukalos traveled
to Walker Air Force Base
in Roswell, New Mexico to meet
with the city's mayor, Del
Jurney, and to get a
rare look at the hangar
where the Roswell wreckage
and extraterrestrial bodies
were allegedly first taken.
Wow!
This is huge.
So what do you think?
Man, I have
goosebumps right now.
I mean, we're
walking on history.
It's amazing, isn't it?
Are you familiar where the
spot is, what it actually--
Well, the
information that I have
says that it was probably
right over here in the corner.
They took them over there, did
an examination of the bodies.
So this is where it was.
This is it, yeah.
Come on in.
They had the debris out
here in the hangar area,
and they bring the
bodies inside this room.
I really don't
know what to say.
Because if this was
it, you're standing
where extraterrestrial
beings might have been.
Where did the debris go?
Where did it end up?
Well, it ended up with
the government, of course.
My understanding
is that they took
the bodies to Wright-Patterson
Air Force Base.
Certainly probably took the
debris as well and have it
well-preserved in a military
installation someplace.
NARRATOR: Roswell
researchers suggest
a government-sanctioned
bond of secrecy
has prevented witnesses
of the crash and retrieval
from coming forward publicly.
But many did choose to
come forward later in life,
including the first
military officer
to arrive at the Roswell crash
site, Major Jesse Marcel.
According to his
grandson, Marcel
privately shared many details of
his experience with the family.
JESSE MARCEL: My
grandfather, Major Jesse
Marcel, he was head
of intelligence
for the 509th bombing group.
As a kid, basically,
around the dinner table,
we talked about Roswell.
And through conversations, we
learned that my grandfather was
the lead investigator
into what has become
known as the Roswell incident.
And when he was
looking at the debris,
he couldn't make heads
or tails or any sense
out of what he was looking at.
He had gathered
some of the debris
and decided to take
it home with him.
He came to this idea that--
he said, whatever this stuff
is, it's very significant.
It's going to change humanity.
And I want my family
to be part of it.
This is very important.
NARRATOR: According
to the family's story,
Major Marcel came home after
his first visit to the site
and laid the debris out on
the floor of their kitchen.
Some of the material was
a strange, thin metal
similar to foil, except when
crumpled up into a ball,
it would bounce back
to its flawless state.
Marcel also claims the metal
was not the same material
featured in
newspaper photographs
being held by his grandfather.
There's a pretty
famous picture
of him holding a piece of debris
which is just a piece of foil,
basically.
And it was weather
balloon material.
He begrudgingly went along
with the story, held it.
And if you take a look at
that, you'll notice that he's
not looking at the camera.
He's looking up at somebody
barking him orders.
He fell in line begrudgingly and
did what he was supposed to do.